we're heading towards a
draw in this game that means tie breaks
it also means duda wins the tournament
and liam liam must be very aware of that
right now he has been fighting hard
trying out different stuff he's tried
and yeah unfortunately not enough jordan
just too solid um the opening choice may
be wrong for liam this is the last trick
and and liam has covered it straight
away i think uh he was hoping for the
king to retreat when actually white
would have won again but with this move
it's a draw black rook locks it down and
actually white here has to be slightly
careful you have to go for the draw
immediately because white's bishop and
white's knight are attacked at the same
time a little bit of nervous time for
duder then you know still two moves away
dude now from winning the tournament oh
you know a draw is inevitable now after
the bishop disappears everything's
disappearing it's king versus king
double fist
young christopher duda wins the oslo
esports cup we see some
congratulations
from his fellow players